***
Riesige Höhlensysteme,
kilometertief unter der Erde,
in denen es
trotzdem nicht komplett dunkel ist
und in denen Völker
richtig große Städte bauen.
Das Underdark
ist in Dungeons&Dragons (D&D)
die Heimat des Bösen.
Kampagnen dort
sind echt kein Spaziergang.
Aber wir zeigen euch heute,
wie lebensfeindlich
das Underdark tatsächlich wäre.
Tag, Jack Pop hier.
D&D ist für mich echt ein Phänomen.
Seit fast 50 Jahren
wird das gespielt,
mit Zettel und Stift,
als Pen and Paper.
Ob das jetzt hier in der realen Welt
ist oder bei den Nerds.
I never played D&D
with girls before.
Don't worry, no one has.
Oder bei den coolen Kids.
*unverständlich*
Wie ist das bei euch?
Kennt ihr D&D,
habt ihr es schon mal gespielt?
Und wenn ja, mit welchem Charakter?
Schreibt mir das in die Kommentare.
Nehmen wir einen Drink.
- Super!
Wir steigen jetzt auf jeden Fall
richtig tief ein ins Thema,
also kilometertief unter die Erde.
Und was uns dort
im Underdark erwartet,
das erzählt uns jetzt
Michael von den Rocketbeans.
Das Underdark ist ein großes
Labyrinth aus Höhlen und Gängen.
Es liegt unter
den vergessenen Reichen.
Es ist eine Ansammlung von
ziemlich wilden und weirden Dingen,
grausigen Kreaturen.
Es wird eingeteilt
in 3 verschiedene Bereiche,
nämlich einmal das Upperdark.
Das geht
bis zu ungefähr 5 Kilometern Tiefe.
Dann kommt das Middledark,
das geht bis zu 16 Kilometern Tiefe.
Alles, was da drunter ist,
ist das Lowerdark.
Und je tiefer man kommt, desto
gefährlicher und weirder wird es.
Alles klar?
- Ja.
Danke, Michael.
16 Kilometer tief unter der Erde.
Holy shit!
Das, was wir als Menschheit bislang
als tiefste Stelle hinbekommen haben,
sind 12 Kilometer, und das
ist ein Bohrloch in Russland.
Also nicht mal ein Höhlensystem,
sondern nur so eine Bohrung.
Ich bin ziemlich gespannt,
was wir über die Region unter
der Erdoberfläche alles wissen.
Und Expertise in diesem Bereich
gibt es heute
von einer guten Bekannten von mir.
Nämlich von Geologin Sophie Erhardt.
Sophie hat Geowissenschaften
an der Uni Bremen studiert
und dann
im Bereich Hydrogeologie promoviert.
Das Underdark betritt sie gar nicht.
Privat sucht sie lieber
den Ausweg aus Escape-Rooms.
Sophie, schön, dass du da bist.
- Danke für die Einladung.
Du bist nicht nur da,
um uns was über D&D zu erzählen.
Sondern du sollst auch noch
mit diesem Klischee aufräumen,
was wir
von Geologinnen und Geologen haben.
Zum Beispiel aus Big Bang Theory.
I will turn on some rock music.
Thats a geology joke.
He is a geologist.
And a joker.
Du kennst die Szene?
- Ich finde es lustig.
Ja, ich auch.
Aber wir reden nicht
über Big Bang Theory.
Wir reden über D&D
und das Underdark.
Da ist an erster Stelle mal wichtig,
woher haben wir denn unsere
Erkenntnisse übers Erdinnere?
Das ist ein total spannendes Thema.
Es ist ein bisschen so
wie bei der Tiefsee.
Wir wissen mehr Dinge nicht,
als wir wissen.
Du hattest diese Bohrung
angesprochen, 12 Kilometer Tiefe.
Das klingt nicht so viel.
Aber es ist technisch gesehen
schon krass.
Die haben über 20 Jahre gebraucht,
um so tief zu kommen.
Es musste einmal die komplette
Bohranlage gewechselt werden.
Da muss man auch
mit Materialien herumexperimentieren?
Das Hauptproblem ist die Temperatur.
In der Tiefe sind dann
ungefähr 180-200 Grad Celsius.
Das hat das Material an die Grenze
seiner Leistungsfähigkeit gebracht.
Das ist echt viel,
180 Grad in nur 12 Kilometern Tiefe.
Dann können wir fürs Underdark
auf jeden Fall was festhalten.
Solche Eiswelten oder großen
Wasserflächen, die wir dort sehen.
Das ist ja dann Quatsch?
- Ja, absolut unrealistisch.
Was ich mich jetzt frage,
wenn die tiefste Bohrung
12 Kilometer tief ist,
woher haben wir dann die ganzen
Informationen über das Erdinnere?
Wir wissen noch aus der Schule,
die Erde
ist schalenförmig aufgebaut.
Erdkern, Erdmantel, Erdkruste.
Das alles
hat physikalische Eigenschaften.
Woher weiß man das?
Das meiste,
was wir übers Erdinnere wissen,
wissen wir über indirekte Methoden,
zum Beispiel durch Erdbeben.
Über die Wellen, die dann ausgesendet
werden und zurückkommen?
Das stimmt, genau.
Du kennst wahrscheinlich
diese horizontale Ausbreitung
von Erdbebenwellen.
Aber das Ganze
verläuft auch quer ins Innere.
Je nachdem, welches Material
diese Wellen durchqueren,
haben die
unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeiten.
Die Wellen laufen schneller
durch sehr dichtes Material.
Wenn wir weniger dichtes haben,
laufen die langsamer.
Dann messen wir an
verschiedenen Stellen auf der Erde
die Ankunftsgeschwindigkeiten
der Wellen.
Dann können wir sagen, was für
Material im Inneren durchquert wurde
und können somit Rückschlüsse
aufs Erdinnere ziehen.
Daher wissen wir, dass die Erde
schalenförmig aufgebaut ist.
Lass uns beim Schalenmodell bleiben.
Wenn wir das
aufs Underdark beziehen,
dann sind wir von der Tiefe her, 16
Kilometer, ja noch in der Erdkruste.
Über Temperaturen
haben wir schon gesprochen.
Aber was wissen wir
denn noch über die Tiefe?
Du kannst dir vorstellen,
dass der Druck immer weiter steigt,
je tiefer wir gehen.
Das kennt jeder
vom Tauchen im Schwimmbad.
Und je tiefer du gehst,
desto mehr Material an Gestein
ist natürlich auch über dir.
Das heißt, so tief hätte man viele
hundert Male den Druck über sich
und an sich,
wie er auf Meereshöhe wäre.
Dann ist es schwer vorstellbar,
dass es da Hohlräume gibt
oder Höhlensysteme,
die stabil halten.
So wie wir es bei D&D sehen.
Höhlen, wie wir sie kennen,
sind meistens nur oberflächennah.
Die tiefste Höhle, die bisher
bekannt ist, liegt in Vietnam.
Und die geht gerade mal
500 Meter ins Erdinnere.
Dass so eine Höhle
überhaupt entsteht,
dafür haben wir meist
Karstgebiete oder Salzstöcke.
Wo lösliche Stoffe
mit Hilfe von Wasser gelöst
und abtransportiert werden.
Dafür brauchen wir 1. Wasser,
was bis dorthin kommt.
Und 2., das Wasser muss
auch den Stoff abtransportieren.
Bei den besprochenen Temperaturen,
ist das nicht möglich.
Genau, und halt der Druck.
Da passiert so viel Metamorphes
mit dem Gestein,
das wird gepresst,
gefaltet, verschoben.
Da ist ein Hohlraum
einfach in keinster Weise zu denken.
Wir können hier aber festhalten,
also mit der Tiefe
hat es dann D&D
ein bisschen übertrieben.
Es sei denn natürlich,
der Planet, auf dem Underdark liegt,
ist jetzt irgendwie komplett
anders aufgebaut als unser Planet.
Aber das
sieht halt auch nicht so aus.
Der hat auch einen Äquator-Umfang
von ungefähr 40.000 Kilometern.
Er ist von seinem Stern aus gesehen
auch der 3. Planet.
Er hat auch einen Mond.
Und wir sehen in den Darstellungen
teilweise auch so Magma-Flüsse.
Das heißt, da würde es
ja auch noch mal heißer sein
mit dem flüssigen Gestein.
Genau,
Magma hat so ungefähr 700 °C.
Das würde natürlich auch
ordentlich Hitze abstrahlen.
Schön angenehme Temperaturen
zum Leben.
Also das haut nicht hin.
Das Underdark müsste sehr viel
weiter an der Oberfläche liegen.
Aber wenn das so wäre, was wäre dann
mit den ganzen anderen Dingen,
die wir da erzählt bekommen?
Jetzt würde man denken, dass es
tief unter der Erde dunkel ist.
Aber die Tunnel des Underdark
werden erleuchtet von Magie
oder von riesigen Pilzen,
die Nightlights genannt werden.
Die sind biolumineszierend,
leuchten aus sich heraus
und können
bis zu 3 Meter hoch werden.
Biolumineszierende Lebewesen,
ohne dir zu nahetreten zu wollen,
ist nicht ganz
deine Expertise als Geologin.
Stimmt, aber ich weiß, dass es
Insekten machen, die Glühwürmchen
oder super viele Fische
in der Tiefsee.
Ja, und auch so Quallen.
Ich finde es mega cool
und wollte mehr dazu erfahren.
Deswegen habe ich nachgefragt
beim Deutschen Zentrum für
integrative Biodiversitätsforschung.
Und dort bei Anton Potapov.
Hey, Jack.
(englisch) Die Menschen erfanden
die Glühbirne erst vor 200 Jahren.
Aber die Natur hat viele Arten
mit Licht ausgestattet
seit dutzenden Millionen Jahren.
Und zwar aus verschieden Gründen.
Um Beute oder Partner anzulocken,
als Tarnung oder zur Kommunikation.
Biolumineszierende Arten
existieren in fast allen Reichen.
Es gibt allein
über 100 biolumineszierende Arten
im Reich der Pilze.
Zum Beispiel
ist das der Honiggelbe Hallimasch
oder der Leuchtende Ölbaumpilz.
Die Art, wie manche Pilze leuchten,
hat sogar einen eigenen Namen,
Foxfire.
Das Licht wird erzeugt
durch eine Oxidationsreaktion
zwischen einem Stoff,
der Luciferin heißt,
und Luciferase, einem Enzym,
das das Luciferin oxidiert.
Das ist also
eine chemische Reaktion,
bei welcher Energie
in Form von Licht freigesetzt wird.
Und so leuchtet der Pilz.
Das ist schon ziemlich cool.
Aber damit so ein Pilz jetzt riesige
Höhlensysteme beleuchten kann,
muss der natürlich
auch entsprechend groß sein.
Bei D&D erreichen
die teilweise bis zu 3 Meter Größe.
Das gibt es so in der Realität nicht,
hat mir Anton erzählt.
Aber es gibt den Riesenbovist,
und der
kommt zumindest in die Richtung.
Der kann nämlich in einem
gut ausgewachsenen Stadium
tatsächlich so einen Durchmesser
von gut einem Meter erreichen.
Und das ist schon ordentlich.
Und man muss sagen, das, was man
sieht, das an der Oberfläche,
das ist ja der kleinste Teil
des Pilzes, dieser Fruchtkörper.
Das, was wirklich richtig groß ist,
ist das Mycel,
was unter der Erde ist.
Und deswegen
ist das größte Lebewesen,
das wir hier auf der Erde kennen,
auch ein Pilz.
Nämlich ein Dunkler Hallimasch,
den man in einem Nationalpark
in Oregon gefunden hat.
Der erstreckt sich dort auf einer
Fläche von 9 Quadratkilometern.
Das sind ungefähr
1.200 Fußballfelder
oder 560.000 nebeneinanderstehende
ausgewachsene Elefanten.
Oder ein paar Milliarden
Pen-and-Paper-Bleistifte.
Auf jeden Fall unfassbar groß.
Das Coole ist, Anton hat mir erzählt,
dass man unter Laborbedingungen
herausgefunden hat,
dass einige Hallimasch-Arten
ein leuchtendes Mycel haben.
Wenn wir uns das jetzt mal
auf 9 Quadratkilometer Fläche
vorstellen wollen.
Dann können wir uns auch vorstellen,
dass das Underdark
schön hell erleuchtet wäre.
Es gibt aber
eine wichtige Voraussetzung.
Anton hat erzählt, dass dieses
Leuchten durch Oxidation entsteht.
Wir bräuchten also Sauerstoff,
damit das was wird.
Generell kann Sauerstoff
jetzt auch nicht verkehrt sein,
wenn wir Leben
im Underdark haben wollen.
Deswegen lasst uns jetzt schauen,
wie es mit diesem wichtigen Element
tief unter der Erde aussieht.
Im Underdark leben
zum einen ganzen normale Tiere
wie zum Beispiel Salamander,
Spinnen, Ratten
und allerhand Ungetier.
Aber natürlich auch ganz
normale Zivilisationen und Völker.
Wie zum Beispiel die Drows, Zwerge,
allerhand Goblin-Stämme und Orks.
Die leben teilweise
sogar in großen Städten,
wie zum Beispiel Menzoberranzan,
die Stadt der Spinnen.
Oder Gracklstugh,
die Stadt der Klingen.
Das ist die Frage
nach Leben in der Tiefe.
Eigentlich
haben wir so große Höhlensysteme
und unterirdische Welten
vorhin schon abgewählt.
Jetzt ist es bei D&D ja so,
es ist eine magische Welt.
Es gibt eine magische Strahlung,
die eben doch dieses Leben unterhalb
der Oberfläche möglich macht.
Die gibt es bei uns
im echten Leben nicht.
Heißt das,
dass grundsätzlich Leben in der Tiefe
so ein bisschen
ausgeschlossen ist?
Na ja, da frage ich jetzt dich,
was bräuchten wir denn für Leben?
Sauerstoff, haben wir gesagt.
Ich würde sagen,
Wasser brauchen wir trotzdem.
Und irgendeine Energiequelle,
eine Form von Energie.
Hm, ich habe schon mal
gute Neuigkeiten für dich.
Also Sauerstoff
gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Man weiß, dass die Hälfte der
Erdkruste aus Sauerstoff besteht.
Aber der ist halt nicht frei
verfügbar, sondern fest gebunden,
also fest in Mineral-Gittern
gebunden, in Silikaten zum Beispiel.
Wir bräuchten also erst mal
einen Prozess oder eine Technik,
der diesen Sauerstoff
verfügbar macht.
Ähnlich ist das mit dem Wasser.
Auch dieses Wasser
ist im Gestein gespeichert.
Und da gab es jetzt letztes Jahr
eine spannende Studie
von der Uni Frankfurt.
Die haben einen Diamanten
aus Botswana untersucht.
Die konnten damit nachweisen,
dass selbst in 600 Kilometern Tiefe
immer noch Wasser verfügbar ist.
Das sind richtig
beträchtliche Mengen, die dort sind.
Und vorher wurde es nur vermutet.
Jetzt hat man letztes Jahr
den Beweis gefunden,
dass also
mit dem Abtauchen von Platten
auch Ozeanwasser
bis ins Erdinnere kommt.
Wow!
Und die hohe Temperatur
sorgt dann auch nicht dafür,
dass dieses Wasser
irgendwie rausgelöst wird?
Das ist ja jetzt
nicht Wasser in der Form,
wie wir es kennen,
also wie Eis im festen Zustand
oder wie Meerwasser als flüssiger
Zustand oder als Wasserdampf.
Sondern es sind
die Bestandteile von Wasser
fest in das Kristallgitter
mit eingebunden.
Aber wo du
die Temperatur ansprichst,
da gibt es tatsächlich ein Problem,
nämlich für die DNA.
Was ja
die Grundlage für alles Leben ist.
Weil die
auch eine Maximaltemperatur hat?
Ja, genau.
Bisher geht man davon aus, dass
Leben nur bis 150 °C möglich ist.
Weil danach
die DNA so schnell zerfällt,
dass kein Reparatursystem mehr,
was uns bis jetzt bekannt ist,
damit überhaupt klarkommen könnte.
Aber das würde ja auch heißen,
dass bis zu einer Tiefe
von so Temperaturen um 150 Grad
Leben nicht
grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen ist.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist auch
ziemlich beeindruckend und krass.
Man hat gefunden,
dass in 5-10 Kilometern Tiefe
immer noch richtig,
richtig viel lebt.
Und vielleicht sogar dort mehr
Leben sein könnte als oberirdisch.
Aber ich nehme mal an,
das sind keine Gnome oder Riesen
oder andere D&D-Kreaturen.
Nein, viel, viel kleiner,
nämlich unzählige Bakterien
oder andere Mikroben im Gestein.
Das ist schon
ziemlich beeindruckend.
Jetzt haben wir
ja auch über Energie gesprochen.
Wo beziehen die die her?
Da ist ja kein Sonnenlicht da.
Es gibt
auch keine magische Strahlung.
Also,
wo haben die ihre Energie her?
Die benutzen
die chemischen Substanzen,
die im Gestein vorkommen, also
Wasserstoff, Methan oder Metalle.
Und einige ernähren sich
auch von der Radioaktivität
des umliegenden Gesteins.
Es ist total irre.
Also kilometertief unter der Erde
gibt es kleine Lebewesen,
die sich
von Radioaktivität ernähren.
Was ja dann auch wieder eine Form
von magischer Strahlung ist.
Könnte man so sagen.
Aber ich muss auch zugeben,
die verbrauchen halt
viel, viel weniger Energie.
An der Erdoberfläche geht es
viel um Wachstum und Vermehrung,
aber im Erdinneren
geht es fast nur ums Existieren.
Man weiß nicht mal, ob die sich
vermehren und weiter teilen.
Ganz viele Sachen
sind noch unbekannt.
Aber natürlich
ist das ein superspannendes Thema.
Okay, aber dann können wir
ja hier schon mal was festhalten.
Leben, das kilometertief
im Erdinneren stattfindet,
das gibt es tatsächlich.
Nur halt nicht so komplex,
wie wir es jetzt
bei D&D mitbekommen.
Aber wenn wir das Underdark
einfach ein bisschen weiter
an die Erdoberfläche bringen.
Dann könnten wir riesige Flächen
mit biolumineszierenden Pilzen
ausstatten.
Und dann steht auch waghalsigen
Kampagnen nichts mehr im Weg.
Sophie, tausend Dank, dass du dich
auf das Abenteuer eingelassen hast.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Danke müssen wir
auch noch sagen an Anton,
der uns die Welt der leuchtenden
Pilze nähergebracht hat.
Und natürlich auch Michael
von den Rocketbeans
fürs Erklären des Underdarks.
Flitzt mal zu denen auf den Kanal
und lasst etwas Liebe von uns da.
Mich würde noch interessieren,
wie hat euch diese Folge gefallen?
Und wollt ihr euch den D&D-Film
im Kino anschauen?
Schreibt das in die Kommentare.
Und vergesst bitte auf gar keinen
Fall, diesen Kanal ...
... zu abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns
ganz bald wieder.
Tschüs.
- Tschüs.
Pilzsuppe jetzt.
Mehr D&D-Content
gibt es bei den Rocketbeans.
Wenn ihr Bock auf mehr Science-Checks
habt, dann schaut mal hier vorbei.
Da haben wir
einen "mind flayer" erklärt.
Copyright MDR 2023